Will Ferrell and John C. Reilly are one of
the most dynamic comedy duos in Hollywood,
having previously joined forces to split sides
in Step Brothers and Talladega Nights: The
Ballad of Ricky Bobby.
"Don't you stick that knife in your leg!"
But sadly, Ferrell and Reilly's latest venture,
the Sherlock Holmes spoof Holmes & Watson,
looks like a total bust.
Professional critics and a horde of Twitter
randos alike say the film is so bad that some
audience members are leaving theaters before
the credits roll, with some even requesting
refunds.
Directed by Tropic Thunder and Idiocracy co-writer
Etan Cohen, Holmes & Watson opened on Christmas
Day 2018, but wasn't screened to members of
the media ahead of its wide launch.
Once critics and fans actually feasted their
eyes upon what ought to have been another
hilarious Ferrell-Reilly two-hander, things
went sour fast.
As of the making of this video, Holmes & Watson
sits at a bleak five percent critical approval
rating and 26 percent fan score on Rotten
Tomatoes.
One viewer wrote bluntly on Twitter,
"Holmes and Watson was the worst f---ing movie
of all time.
First movie I've ever walked out on."
'What?
Were you saying something?"
Another random enraged moviegoer tweeted,
"@HolmesAndWatson is an absolute disaster.
Had to wake up 3 other family members 40 minutes
in just to walk out.
Possibly overtakes Ishtar as worse movie of
all time!
Don't waste your $ or time!"
"That doesn’t make sense.”
1987's Ishtar, starring Warren Beatty and
Dustin Hoffman, is widely considered to be
one of the worst cinematic disasters ever,
with Roger Ebert calling it at the time, quote,
"a lifeless, massive, lumbering exercise in
failed comedy."
"Do it!”
“AYE AYE YEE AYE AYE"
So, not exactly great company!
Bailing on a flick forty minutes in is pretty
bad.
But it gets worse: A woman shared that she
and her boyfriend ...
"...walked out of Holmes and Watson 15 minutes
in.
Boyfriend's movie choosing privileges are
cancelled."
Yikes!
So what went wrong?
On paper, Holmes & Watson has everything going
for it: Ferrell and Reilly playing goofy versions
of Arthur Conan Doyle's classic characters,
a talented screenwriter sitting in the director's
seat, and a first-rate UK cast, including
Ralph Fiennes.
In practice, however, nothing really worked.
Critics have set aflame just about every aspect
of Holmes & Watson, denouncing the lazy and
out-of-control direction, the unfunny script
that misses the mark as a parody, and all
the heavy-handed references and jokes that
completely fall flat.
In his review, Newsday's Rafer Guzmán described
Holmes & Watson as,
"[...] one of those movies that goes beyond
unfunny and into a comedy-cubist zone, where
jokes are no longer recognizable and laughter
is philosophically impossible."
Noel Murray of the Los Angeles Times was a
bit nicer, calling the film,
"[...] more of a well-meaning misfire than
a total train wreck, [...] frustrating mainly
because all of these folks can do much better."
Murray added that many of the actors looked,
quote, "befuddled about what they're supposed
to be doing," which is never a good sign.
Peter Sobczynski from RogerEbert.com was far
more brutal in his half-star review, writing,
"Holmes & Watson is so excruciatingly awful
that you have to wonder what it was, other
than their paychecks, that could have possessed
the cast and crew to keep coming back each
day, when it must have been obvious from the
first day of shooting that the project was
the most hopeless of cases imaginable."
So, if you're looking for a laugh, the answer
appears elementary: avoid Holmes & Watson
at all costs.
"Yeah, no s--- Sherlock!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.